right so they've tell us exactly what is
this first of all tell us the name of
the job what does it do so the job is
chairman of as you said the Public
Company Accounting Oversight Board which
is called PCAOB they are a entity
created by Congress after the accounting
scandals of the late 90s early 2000s
when Enron and others were found to have
cooked their books and the auditors
didn't never blew the whistle on it or
didn't find the fraud so they created
Congress created this entity it
effectively regulates audit firms
accounting firms that audit the
financial statements of public companies
okay so who is the chief regulator or
auditor of accounting firms currently
and why does the job pay so much so the
Chairman now is that man named James
Doty he's a Republican and the the
salary which is over six hundred
thousand dollars for the chairman is
really high it's high relative to even
other financial regulatory agencies and
it's high because there was the notion
that you had to compensate the Chairman
really well and the board members really
well in order to keep them independent
in other words to keep them from having
some temptation to go check out of these
jobs and go work for the accounting
industry or other or other industries
that are regulated by the PCAOB or
entities like the SEC and just quickly
de veau who appoints the head of this
this agency this organization the
Securities Exchange Commission the the
five commissioners of the SEC actually
appoint the chairman and the other board
members of the PCAOB the PCAOB is
effectively in many ways answerable to
the SEC